so the scientists have just kind of done
these experiments where they gave these
people foods that didn't contain any
gluten or wheat but they told them it
did and they still experienced all of
the symptoms that shows us that their
symptoms aren't imagined they really
were experiencing them but it's like the
kind of opposite of the placebo effect
the expectation that they will become
ill makes them feel the symptoms
david robson welcome to the show
yeah thanks so much for having me
how did you get interested in the way
that expectations can impact our lives
like i guess like as a medical writer
i've kind of known about the placebo
effect for ages um but then i just like
over the last five years i've just seen
like such an abundance of research that
had kind of moved beyond like you know
the effects in hospitals but to like all
other areas of our lives so you know
like um there is you know some great
research on these kind of weird
psychogenic illnesses that pass between
people just through expectations but
then also my research looking at the way
our expectations shape our performance
at the gym like how we respond to sleep
loss even like how quickly we age um and
it was actually that finding i just
thought i have to write this book now
because it's like it's actually cutting
people's lives by like seven and a half
years like if you have this negative
view of aging if you see it as this kind
of period of inevitable decline and that
just seems so profound it felt like
actually you know you could do a lot of
good by telling this story basically
what's the difference between the
expectation effect and the placebo
effect
so the placebo effect is like one type
of expectation effect and so that is
like um i guess most people are familiar
with it but that's very much like if you
have high expectations that a treatment
is going to be effective even if it's a
dummy treatment um then you will see
some kind of um alleviation of your
symptoms um so that's been researched
for like five decades you know like
there's no longer any controversy over
that um but the expectation effect is
kind of much more general so this is
looking at how we create self-fulfilling
prophecies um
uh from our beliefs through like
various mechanisms so changes to our
behavior changes to our um perception
and changes to our physiology and that
happens both positively and negatively
right this isn't us just making things
better we can also make things worse
yeah and i think that's how it often
manifests in our lives like day to day
is that when we have these kind of
negative expectations we're like
needlessly hampering our performance
we're like kind of limiting our
potential essentially so
um so yeah a lot of what i write in the
book is actually just like asking people
to reassess those negative expectations
and just kind of bring it up to
something that's a bit more objective or
open-minded and even that can have a
huge effect on your life
the problem is we have a negativity bias
right we have a leaning generally
towards negativity we're vigilant for
whatever might be lurking in the
bushes of existence and
now that the expectation effect is
something that we know about that
negativity bias bleeds into a reality
negativity bias right we become a
self-fulfilling prophecy of the fears
that we had previously
yeah that's exactly it so it's like the
um one of the researchers told me and i
totally believe this that our
expectations that we have today are kind
of shaping our reality tomorrow so you
know like they are actually shaping the
way we perceive the world but also kind
of physically what's happening to our
bodies um but like you said we have this
negativity bias i think like in our
culture we often see like being
pessimistic as being inherently more
rational or kind of smarter you know
it's smart to be cynical but often we're
just needlessly negative actually our
kind of pessimistic expectations are no
more rational than if we were like a
kind of pollyanna figure who was always
being like totally optimistic about
everything you know so yeah that's where
i think we have to find that sweet spot
where we're not like raising our
expectations to be kind of wishful
thinking but we're just kind of asking
objectively could i see this situation
um kind of more positively essentially
you looked at the expectation effect and
diet right yeah exactly so that's one of
my favorite examples um
and like this is another way i try to
kind of differentiate the expectation
effect from just like positive thinking
you know like bollocks like um the
secret where you kind of you're told to
just imagine yourself being like super
skinny and like you will just become
super skinny um like that's totally not
gonna happen but what the scientific
research shows is that it's much more
about our kind of specific expectations
of the food we're eating um
and so when we're kind of dieting um
we're so focused on like the kind of
sense of deprivation and like you know
all the calories we're missing
that that actually kind of sets up the
body for starvation so it does things
like increases the levels of the hunger
hormone ghrelin that stimulates appetite
and ghrelin also kind of um slows your
metabolism so you burn fat more slowly
essentially so if you're on a diet
you've got this mindset of deprivation
you've got high levels of ghrelin that
are kind of making you have hunger pangs
and like reducing your metabolism it's
like a recipe for disaster it's like
going to make your diet so much harder
um so yeah that was revelatory for me to
just realize that actually
you know very simply kind of the kind of
packaging we see around our diet foods
are actually changing the way our body
responds to the food
is that language like low calorie
snack and stuff like that
yeah all of that kind of thing and you
know like they um the scientists did
this kind of linguistic analysis of kind
of diet foods and it's it's not just
like focusing on the low calories it's
also like they miss out on all of the
vocabulary that might help you to get
pleasure out of food so you know like if
you have a high fat food it's going to
be like a luxurious decadent you know
like um
uh you know
yeah creamy tasty they're going to focus
on all of the kind of sensory aspects if
you have a diet food it's like sensible
which is like such a bland horrible word
and then like that actually changes your
hormonal response to the food just by
having that kind of language that sets
you up to feel like you're depriving
yourself
interesting so
there is a balance i suppose for
marketers that are doing food marketing
between
the
i guess the conversion in terms of
whether people are going to pick it up
and then the enjoyment or the
effectiveness of whether or not it
actually satiates people a bit more what
was the didn't you look at something to
do with french people aren't french
people supposed to be really
fat and they're not
yeah right exactly because they eat a
lot of food that's kind of high in
saturated fats um
so they should have higher levels of
kind of cardiovascular disease um
because of this and yet they don't they
actually
you know they like um have lower bmis
but also just lower rates of heart
attacks compared to like america and the
uk even though we eat like fewer
saturated fats and so that's kind of
this mystery but then you look at the
french kind of whole attitude to eating
and they just don't feel this kind of
guilt around what they eat that we have
in the uk or us so
um it's like there was this survey that
asked um it's like word association and
like what do you associate with cream
cake and in france it was like
celebration and in the uk it was guilt
regret yeah yeah exactly and so the idea
here is that actually if you're feeling
like totally stressed about the food
you're eating all the time and you're
missing out on all of that pleasure
that's like a major source of stress and
we know that stress itself can kind of
contribute to ill health so like you
know day to day you're not going to
notice the difference but over a
lifetime it can help to explain the
differences between those cultures in
terms of the kind of illnesses that they
experience
what was that thing that you looked at
to do with gluten and gluten
intolerances
um yeah i mean this maybe is a bit
controversial so there are some people
that definitely have a gluten
intolerance like there's just no
question about that it's like they're
you know their body is responding to it
it's got a true allergic reaction um so
i'm not questioning that but like i
think recently we've seen a lot of media
coverage where people don't have like a
celiac disease but they're just kind of
gluten sensitive or wheat sensitive so
you know about 30 of people now report
that and it's you know
that has kind of increased from a couple
of percent to 30 in like 10 years it
would be crazy if like our bodies were
changing that quickly
um
and then the scientists have just kind
of done these experiments where they
gave these people these foods that
didn't contain any gluten or wheat but
they told them it did contain the gluten
and weight and they still experienced
all of the symptoms so they were still
having like the bloating or the diarrhea
like all of this um stuff so like that
shows us that their symptoms
aren't imagined like they really were
experiencing them but it's through an
expectation effect it's like the kind of
opposite of the placebo effect it's like
the expectation of that they will become
ill makes them feel the symptoms um and
that probably can explain the rise like
the essentially all the media coverage
about wheat sensitivity is kind of
making a lot of people ill
wow it's like a
a psychological contagion in a way and
if you're hearing a lot of news stories
about this is how bad gluten is for you
and this is how you're going to react
and this is how you're going to respond
and maybe you've got a friend who's got
it as well and
it doesn't surprise me that that stuff
happened but it's so hilarious it's such
an interesting intersection right
because
people don't have a gluten intolerance
or they they um might not have as severe
of a gluten intolerance as their body is
responding to
however they are
suffering
with the effects of a gluten intolerance
so it is it is not quite the same as the
placebo effect right it's
it's this it's in some sort of no man's
land in between the two they don't have
the problem but they do have the impact
but they don't have it for the reason
that they thought that they did
yeah that's exactly it and i think
actually like a lot of people find it
quite offensive if you suggest it's kind
of the origin is psychological rather
than like purely biological but actually
like i don't think that distinction
makes sense anymore when we understand
the mind-body connection because we know
that like our expectations can change
our physiology so
you know loads of other experiments have
shown that like if you're expecting to
kind of have a headache
that expectation then actually changes
the release of like different chemicals
in your brain that change the
vasculature of of your brain so it's
actually like changing the pressure that
causes the headache
so if you take a kind of tablet and you
expect to have a headache um
like it's not the biological action
that's going to give you that headache
but you're still going to feel the pain
and it's still actually caused to change
you know within the brain itself it's
still it's like the words of
biologically active rather than the pill
you're taking essentially and we're
saying exactly the same
thing with um the wheat intolerance it's
like the expectation is biologically
active it's not the food you're eating
that's actually causing that problem i
think the reason and i could
totally imagine if i had some
illness or
allergy of some kind that i've been
dealing with for a long time and then
somebody comes in and says what this is
potentially contributed to or worsened
by your psychology
that makes you feel culpable that makes
you feel like it's your
fault almost and like you're in control
the reason that people like the idea of
medicalizing or at least it makes them
feel more secure is that by giving
something a term by branding it as
something it it kind of makes it feel
more
realistic more real more medicalized
more scientific and probably a little
bit more like um it's not their fault
yeah totally yeah and i think like
that's something that has been contra uh
contributed to by like the medical
profession in that like i think a lot of
doctors have this kind of assumption
actually that if something's psychogenic
it's kind of not real it's imaginary you
know they have kind of assumed it's kind
of malingering so often like doctors can
be quite rude when they present this
diagnosis that something's psychogenic
in origin
um not psychology more upsetting i said
that's just like if it's psychological
in origin essentially so if it um comes
from like the brain not from like a
biological direct biological action um
yeah and that i mean it's so damaging
and then like so these people then feel
very resistant to the diagnosis
they're not really going to be very
positive about say having like a
cognitive behavioral therapy to try to
treat this psychogenic illness so
they're like stuck in this leaf it's
actually much harder to treat them than
it would be often to treat someone with
a purely biological illness no way so
somebody that's got a psychogenic
uh gluten intolerance is potentially
more difficult to treat than somebody
who has a biologically driven gluten
intolerance that's
that's so interesting
yeah it's crazy i mean and because
there's like loads of other psychogenic
illnesses that are like even more severe
so what are some good examples
like some people have psychogenic
blindness where they
their brain has kind of fooled them into
thinking that their eyes can't see and
then so they actually can't see like
it's actually their brain is just
blocking that sensory information from
being processed consciously
and again or paralysis even like some
people have like paralyzed limbs they're
caused by like the expectation that it's
been paralyzed somehow without a kind of
biological damage anatomical damage um
and for those people yeah like it's
really difficult then to try to get them
to respond to treatment because
it feels so insulting and there's such
stigma attached to that even though it
shouldn't be because actually
you know all of us are kind of
experiencing these expectation effects
to a greater or lesser degree
it's just like you know they're having a
more extreme reaction than most people
one of the places that i noticed this in
my own life was with fasting so
everybody knows the experience of being
hungry and not having eaten it's 2pm and
you still haven't had any food in you or
whatever and you've got those hunger
pangs but
after a bunch of different episodes with
longevity doctors like dr david sinclair
and his colleagues
i realized that maybe that hunger signal
is something that i'm actually seeking
maybe that's something that's good for
me it's a hormesis stressor it's gonna
activate
telomeres and all of the other stuff
that i can't remember and that then
reframed
the experience of being hungry to me i
thought actually this is a signal that
something's going right here like this
is the
input that i'm after and yeah okay it's
not
wildly enjoyable but it's not that bad
just the sensation of being hungry
without the narrative and the story
around oh my god i need to eat my
energy's going to be low blah blah blah
i actually find that my energy goes up
while i'm hungry i find that i'm more
alert i find that my thoughts are
quicker and i think oh this is good for
me this is something that i'm supposed
to be doing and i'm going to look
forward to having my food in an hour's
time or whatever
yeah i mean that's just like what the
expectation effect is all about is this
kind of process of reframing um so it's
not about denying the feelings it's not
like you're telling yourself like i'm
not hungry but you're just
you're reinterpreting those feelings and
you're kind of telling yourself like
based on the science that it's actually
like a good thing for you and so we see
that with a lot of the other expectation
effects that i discuss like um
when people are working out at the gym
you know like um some people really
catastrophize like when they're kind of
feeling tired like during an endurance
exercise and they they see it as a sign
of that their own fitness is you know
kind of really poor that maybe they're
going to suffer a heart attack or
something um and what you want to do is
just kind of change that interpretation
and be like actually like
you know no pain no gain like if it's if
i'm feeling uncomfortable that's when
i'm doing my body like the most good um
and you can see that when people do
interpret that like it changes a bunch
of things in the body but
especially like it
it kind of helps to encourage the
release of the endogenous opioids that
we have in the brain so like the
endorphins essentially that give you
that run as high like when you
reinterpret your feelings during a
workout and realize that actually like
the feeling of pain can almost almost be
like a reward you get those like the
release of those endorphins it makes you
feel good and it makes you want to come
back to the gym afterwards so
what yeah it's quite powerful what are
some of the examples of this being used
in
sports
yeah i mean there's like loads of
anecdotal evidence of like um coaches
kind of giving um
telling their athletes that they're
taking this kind of banned substance but
they're actually just giving them an
injection of like glucose or whatever
like
um but because the athlete's gonna
believe they've taken this performance
enhancer they do
you know like they have much greater
strength or endurance so
you know it's being used kind of i think
that's ethically dubious like misleading
the athletes and like getting them to
feel that they're taking advanced
substances like you know
um
definitely like some questions and alarm
bells there but i think more generally
like um there's a lot of research just
showing that you a lot of the sport
supplements that we take like the legal
ones are also
kind of better benefiting from a placebo
effect so things like caffeine that we
might take as a muscle stimulant um
actually the research shows that if you
give people decaf but tell them that
it's like high intensity caffeine they
like get a lot stronger um and if you
give them like proper like high dose of
caffeine and told them that it's decaf
they actually get weaker because of that
so it's like yeah it's crazy so actually
most of the benefits from that
supplement is coming from our
expectations not from the chemical
effects
so
another implication here for um
marketers and general branding
is
the
story that you tell people around the
things that they're taking
largely determined their experiences of
it and i'm in austin at the moment and
there is a strong psychedelic community
here and i had do you know hamilton
morris
for hamilton's pharmacopoeia guy who
used to work for vice
ah yeah yeah yeah i do it's a long
stringy kind of chemist guy that goes
and takes drugs all over the world um
i was talking to him about
uh bufo alvarius which was the toad
psychedelic toad and people used to
rub it on a piece of glass and then they
scrape it off and then they smoke the
toad venom and
he
is adamant that you're able to recreate
that chemically one-to-one like it is
the same molecular structure
and yet people still went about using
the toad and there is a whole story
around the fact that it's sacred and he
had the exact same
thought of what you're mentioning there
with regards to the supplements that
literally none of it is to do with the
fact that it's come from a toad and
everything is to do with the fact that
there's this story around the fact that
the toad is sacred and you go on a big
walk to go and find them and you see
them and you spend time with them and
the same thing when people are talking
about psychedelics set and setting those
are the two things that you try and
control what's your intention coming
into this what's the experience being
around this if you're going away to do
an ayahuasca retreat you're fasting for
days beforehand you make sure that you
don't swear you're in this beautiful
surrounding it you've got you know
indigenous music being played and you've
got a headdress on and people are
dousing you in flower petal water and
stuff what is this it's priming it's
story it's narrative it's creating that
expectation that something magical and
positive is about to happen
yeah i mean that's totally it like the
ritual is just so important that it's
like i almost find it surprising that
anyone could think you could separate
the two um because i would say yeah like
in those experiences like maybe
80 of what people are feeling is going
to be from the ritual from the story
like you said uh from the setting and
like very small part is going to come
from the drug i mean we see this in in
medicine with like um
people who are receiving morphine after
an operation um so they could receive
that in their intravenous strip it's
just delivered automatically um or you
can have a doctor give you an injection
and tell you you know this is pain
relief you're going to feel better and
actually to get the same level of pain
relief
you need twice as big a dose when it's
the morphine is administered
surreptitiously without the ritual of
the doctor giving you that morphine so
it's like the placebo effect alone is
like yeah like half of the power of
morphine which is quite crazy
i remember reading a story in one of
johan hari's books about a guy who had a
magic electric
wand thing in the 1800s or the 1900s do
you know this story he used to wave it
over people and then over time they took
different things away
do you know this
i don't know okay so i
these patients were catatonic for one
reason or another maybe it was chronic
pain or back pain or depression or
something and this guy said i've created
this special new device and i'm gonna
wave it over you and it's gonna make
everything better and it was all complex
and maybe it used electricity and it was
wood wrapped in metal with wires and
other stuff and used to wave it over
people and these people that had been
catatonic for years that sometimes got
up and started moving around ah it's a
miracle and over time i can't remember
if it was this guy or if it was somebody
else that was trying to disprove it or
whatever or stress test it started
recreated their own and started taking
bits away from it so first they
unplugged the electricity and then they
removed the wires and then they took
away the metal sheet and then they took
away the wood and then it was just
someone waving their hand over people
and saying the same thing and you end up
with exactly the same outcome
yeah i mean it's incredible and so i
think a lot of well like part of the
placebo effect um
is
just that feeling that someone is kind
of caring for you that can be quite
powerful in itself and we know that that
can do things like um reduce the
inflammation that you feel within your
body so it's almost like um
if you're kind of feeling isolated and
ill your body's like sending loads of
inflammatory markers like that can kind
of they attack pathogens by like brute
force um but when you know that you're
being cared for or that you have kind of
some kind of security the body can like
remove that inflammation and allow like
the more specific parts of your immune
system to kick into action so like the
production of antibodies um so yeah i
feel like the healing ritual in itself
is super important and then on top of
that we have the specific expectations
of what the treatment is going to kind
of give us like what benefits we're
going to get and then that can have more
specific effects on like you know
whether you have like pain relief
whether it like reduces your blood
pressure like all of that kind of stuff
you said that our
beliefs are more powerful than our genes
when it comes to exercise why is that
yeah i mean um so there's this
experiment it was just like a the
exp the scientists like asked these
people to come into the lab they gave
them a genetic test
um
it was looking at the kreb uh chrome one
gene um so that's just uh we know that
that is involved in like um
loads of things to do with like
endurance exercise so kind of how
efficiently your lungs kind of can uh
exchange the carbon dioxide for oxygen
um your like body temperature as you
exercise if you have like the bad
bearing um you just start to feel like
hotter and more uncomfortable like and a
bit more sweaty as you exercise so you
know like it is important but the
scientists gave sham feedback to these
participants so they you know regardless
of what they actually had they told
someone like you have this amazing
variant you're going to be brilliant and
the others were told like you're really
not cut out for exercise like don't
expect much um
so that changed like the endurance on
the treadmill like it did have an
immediate effect on performance but um
actually then it changed the
physiological measures too so actually
if you expected to
have this like great version of the gene
it actually changed the efficiency of
the gas exchange so you know that's kind
of incredible also things like the
efficiency of their movement seem to
have been different um but what's even
more incredible to me was actually they
then compared the size of the
expectation effect to the size of the
actual genetic effect and often the the
expectations were having more of an
effect than the genes itself so whether
you think you're cut out for exercise is
probably more important than the kind of
genome you were born with
wild what did you you looked at michael
phelps for some reason yeah
what do you learn from him
um so he um he'd always said like he
didn't think like his secret was like in
his body but it was more like in his um
amazing ability to visualize exercise so
like in addition to doing all of the
physical training he would like imagine
every race in like my new detailer all
of the turns like every twist of his
body he would plan out um
and then he he said it was like his
visualization was so good that when he
actually got into the pool it was almost
as if he'd done like an extra kind of
training practice
um
and then so that's like really
intriguing but it's kind of anecdotal
but then actually this scientific
research shows that um visualizing
exercise can be really powerful on its
own so there's like this study um they
just got people to kind of imagine like
lifting heavy objects every day for six
weeks um they weren't actually doing any
weight lifting they were just imagining
it um
and then like compared to the beginning
of that period they were like 10
stronger um compared to participants who
hadn't done any kind of
imaginary lifting at all and they were
actually a bit weaker um it sounds
incredible and like i think it's
important to emphasize here that like
the scientists aren't claiming that it
was actually building the muscles
themselves like they didn't have more
kind of muscle mass but what the brain
was doing was kind of recalibrating
what it thought the muscles could
achieve and then that was causing it to
uh recruit more muscle fibers so when we
exercise actually even if we're like
really exerting ourselves we only
recruit about 50 like 50 of our muscle
fibers that's to kind of stop us from
exhausting ourselves and giving us like
more energy reserves if we need it later
um probably when they were doing this
visualization exercise it was just
persuading the brain to maybe recruit a
few more of those muscle fibers which
then made them like physically stronger
even though they didn't have bigger
muscles
a big chunk of what people are doing
when they train in the gym is drilling
that cns
right getting them they're called
movement engrams making sure that you're
moving efficiently that you're doing
things right and i remember hearing
about i i ruptured my achilles uh a year
and a half ago and
my doctor had said to me look throughout
the process of this before you can get
onto doing calf raises you can restrict
the atrophy that you're going to get in
your calf
if you imagine yourself doing calf
raises so
although it was difficult for me to do
because it does the only thing more
boring than doing calf raises is only
imagining that you're doing calf raises
but
sure i would i would do a little working
set
uh on the days that i could be bothered
where i would imagine that i was doing
that i have no idea whether or not it
had an impact but at least it seems like
you know that um atrophy of the cns
would have probably been down regulated
yeah exactly i think that's like um
i mean like that's really where this
word this kind of technique is so
promising is for rehabilitation like you
know like when people break limbs like
they do experience a lot of like um
strength loss um and then this research
has shown that they can kind of cut the
amount of strength that they lose by
about 50 if they imagine doing the
exercises so it's like you know is just
helping them to
it's like giving them a head start when
they do get back to kind of doing their
normal workouts
what did you look at to do with sleep
um yeah this was totally fascinating to
me so um
like scientists can just like get people
into this um
into their labs and get them to sleep
for a night and they can measure like
the brain activity to see if they've
actually been asleep or if it's been
really disturbed um and then you get
people to kind of report how much sleep
they had and in general people's
subjective uh assessment of their sleep
is just really poor so
like almost everyone like overall
underestimates how much they've slept um
so you get this group who are like the
uh complaining
good sleepers so they sleep like eight
hours a night you know no problem there
at all but they might i guess you know
they wake up like in the middle of the
night for like a couple of minutes but
in their head it was like they were
awake for hours and they are totally
convinced that they're going to have in
some the effects of insomnia the next
day um and what you can see is that that
becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy so
they suffer from like poor concentration
you know fatigue
irritability all of these things just
because of their expectations not
because they've suffered any kind of
sleep loss
and the reverse presumably as well for
the people who undersleep but
convince themselves that they've
probably done okay
yeah the non-complaining bad sleepers
are the total opposite so they actually
don't have any of the effects of
insomnia not even like things like high
blood pressure which often comes from
bad sleep loss um they're just
completely immune to all of that um
so i actually kind of personally
identify with that like i
i do think like i do have disruptive
sleep but i also just like try to focus
on the on how much sleep i have got
because i know that like
you know even if it feels quite
disturbed like if you're just kind of
lying there dozing that's better than
like not getting any sleep at all and
yeah so i don't get like a
bad like effects of insomnia whereas
like my partner's the total opposite
like he will like
he sleeps for like nine hours a night
but if he wakes up once he will be like
in a really bad mood the next day
did you look at people who consider
themselves or
think
that they're not going to get to sleep
very easily
in people everyone's familiar with this
you've got a big event tomorrow or
you're going away on holiday and the
flight's early so you get to bed a
little bit earlier than usual and you
end up falling asleep three hours after
your usual bedtime lying awake in bed
thinking i need to get to sleep i'm
going to guess that the expectation
effect must
are you expecting to go to sleep i guess
that you're fulfilling the prophecy of
fearing that you won't
yeah that's exactly it's like you're
raising the anxiety but you won't and
then when you're not getting sleep
you're kind of um
kind of catastrophizing that and
focusing on all of the kind of bad
effects that are going to arise from
that sleep loss um so yeah that's like i
mean it is you know i've experienced
that a lot and it's like a terrible
thing but actually counter-intuitively
the best way to avoid that is to
try to stay awake
um
if you're just like
if you're just like well i'm not gonna
sleep so i'm just gonna like stay awake
here and like you will yourself to stay
awake you kind of cut through all of
that anxiety and ironically then you get
to sleep like more quickly so
yeah that's interesting what about aging
then you said at the start that the
expectation effect can reduce life by
seven years
yeah yeah exactly so um
researchers in the us kind of looked at
these huge like longitudinal studies so
tracking people's kind of lives from you
know like
teen at their teenage years right to
their kind of deaths in their 70s and
80s um and at some point in that you
know like in their 30s they kind of
measured like their expectations of what
was going to happen as they got older so
they asked them you know is it going to
be a time of decline and disability
you're going to kind of lose your
independence or do you see it as this
kind of time of growth you know time of
wisdom like
you know they weren't kind of asking
them like do you deny that there's any
problems that come with aging but just
some people kind of see the good as well
as the bad um
and they found that those um
those kind of views that people had in
midlife then predicted how long they
would live by
um a difference of about seven and a
half years so like a big difference in
longevity um and then later how big the
study was yeah that would have been
thousands of participants so this is a
really representative sample yeah yeah
exactly and then it's been like repeated
again and again with loads of different
samples and they found the expectations
of aging can predict things like um
like your risk of getting alzheimer's
disease like if you have the positive
use it cuts your risk of alzheimer's by
about 50
even if you have the genetic
predisposition to get alzheimer's it
still cuts it by fifty percent
mate this is wild
this is so crazy
so i was like totally skeptical of that
um
but then you know like we were saying
like the studies were well conducted and
they were like big numbers um
and then they the scientists have also
kind of joined the dots to kind of find
the mechanism for how that would happen
um
and so like one is just kind of
behavioral um it's like if you're
defeatist about getting old you're not
going to do so much exercise you're not
going to look after your health you know
that's going to have an effect
um but there's also a kind of
physiological effect here too and that's
like if you feel
vulnerable as you get old um
every challenge in your life is going to
feel like super stressful so that's
going to raise like levels of cortisol
um it raises levels of light
inflammation we know that both of those
things can cause bodily wear and tear
and then you can see the effects right
down to kind of differences within the
cells themselves
so it kind of um the people with the
negative effects have like shorter
telomeres like like you i know you know
this but yeah like those protective caps
that kind of
protect our dna from kind of damage um
and the kind of epigenetic markers
within their cells um it's like the
cells are just ticking at like a quicker
rate if you have the negative beliefs
compared to the positive beliefs
why do you think that this
effect
exists so there's some uh mechanistic
elements of this right like you said the
person and this is not just for aging
but for the the whole effect overall i'm
trying to work out why this is adaptive
i'm trying to work out why it's so
universal why it seems to work across
a million different mechanisms
why have we got this
yeah i mean it's like um i think it's
like just so fundamental to how the
brain works
and what it does is it gives us kind of
flexibility um
so there's like this new idea in kind of
the study of consciousness that the
brain works as this kind of prediction
machine so it's always like building
simulations of what's going on around us
um
that helps us to kind of process the
sensory data
but also just as importantly it's kind
of um
it's allowing the brain to kind of
prepare the body for the challenges that
we're gonna face um
so you know just like adjusting the
levels of your hormones like so that if
you're going to face like a kind of
danger like you're kind of pumped up and
like physically ready to attend to the
threat and you know your psychology is
going to change as well so that you
um are kind of more on the ball and like
uh more capable of kind of of like
focusing on the danger and not kind of
thinking about other stuff like not
being too dozy um so it's actually this
prediction machine is giving us a lot of
flexibility it's allowing us to respond
like second by second to what's going on
around us um
the thing is like those predictions like
sometimes it's purely based on things
like the context of the situation that
you're in um or you know like how much
you've eaten how much you slept you know
like there's definitely like an
objective element to that that the
body's kind of getting from all of its
kind of senses like within the body and
like on the skin um
but also it's just drawing on all of its
previous experiences to kind of
calibrate those predictions um and
that's where like our conscious thinking
and like our expectations and our
interpretations of the events like the
yeah like the way we kind of choose to
frame them that's shaping the
predictions and then it's shaping how
the body responds as well
what do you see as the difference
between creating a positive expectation
and being delusional
yeah i mean that's something like i
really wanted to get clear um in my book
because it's like
um so much of the positive thinking
literature is kind of about being
delusional in a way so it's like you
know we were talking about like your
expectations at the gym like
if someone is like a real couch potato
like going to the gym and telling
themselves that they're like an olympic
athlete it's only going to lead to
disappointment like you cannot be that
delusional that you're really going to
fool yourself so i think like it's
really important to set like realistic
expectations even if you're improving
your expectations it's like always
trying to be kind of honest yourself and
authentic um so like at the gym like i
think like don't tell yourself you're
gonna be you know like a world-class
athlete straight away but like just
reinterpret those feelings that you're
having at the gym like if you're being
like
overly negative about like the fatigue
that you're feeling and you're kind of
catastrophizing that and you're telling
yourself that there's something like
fundamentally wrong with your body
like you just need to reappraise those
feelings and actually look at it much
more objectively and kind of just tell
yourself that actually if you're feeling
fatigued like that is not only normal
but it's desirable it's like you with
fasting it's like you're telling
yourself that yeah like i'm hungry but
that is why i'm doing this like what am
i here for yes yeah exactly so i think
that's how we want to reframe our
feelings is just to be and our
expectations is just to kind of
yet to be honest and to just like avoid
catastrophizing stuff when actually we
can just see it in a more positive light
so the you've got the proximal zone of
development for skill acquisition and
we've got the proximal zone of
expectation
for the expectation effect not too far
not too little certainly not negative
yeah exactly i love that yeah it
definitely has to be a kind of proximal
zone and actually like if we look at the
expectation effect around like stress
and anxiety like it's exactly what
you're describing there and that like um
our culture has always been like really
down on anxiety and seeing it as being
like purely kind of detrimental to your
performance and debilitating um
virtually the science shows us that you
know those stress responses can be
really useful and adaptive like
you know cortisol is kind of sharpening
your mind it's actually helping you to
release kind of glucose into your blood
when your heart is pumping like that
come like really hard that can feel
quite uncomfortable
um but it's actually like getting all
the oxygen around your body into your
brain so it's like preparing you for
like a big challenge um and what the
scientists like
they kind of told some people like
suppress your feelings like just you
know tell yourself i'm calm not anxious
and they told the other people just like
um
just accept your anxiety but recognize
that it might be having these benefits
and that you actually evolved to fill
this for a reason
and then they got them to do things like
difficult public speaking or like um
doing like a tough kind of graduate exam
and i found that actually the kind of
honest reappraisal of the feelings like
not suppressing them but just like
reinterpreting what they meant and like
just questioning like are they actually
detrimental or could they be useful that
that in itself was enough to improve
their performance um
you know on the public speaking on the
exam kind of making them more creative
and like improving their numerical
skills and reducing their anxiety and it
also just helped them to kind of recover
from the anxiety afterwards so
you know like if you've had like a
stressful event like sometimes you can
just feel exhausted for like the whole
day afterwards like you're you're still
kind of charged um but for these people
they weren't they just went back to like
the normal life you know like their body
started like digesting their food
properly again you know their heart rate
returned to normal um and that's really
important for like the long-term effects
of stress because if you can if you have
like a momentary like feeling of stress
but then like recover quickly afterwards
that's not so damaging for your body in
the long term it's the chronic stress
that we're seeing that's super super
damaging to people i have a yeah a
friend comedian bridget fettesey and she
still gets very very nervous before she
goes on stage and she's got a little
mantra that she says to herself she says
i'm not nervous i'm excited i'm not
nervous i'm excited i'm not nervous i'm
excited and
i haven't
i have another friend uh very well known
dj who
frequently throws up before he goes to
do a set because that's how much he
cares because the nerves are in there um
and he now
he's now told me that if he doesn't
throw up before a set he gets concerned
he's more concerned if he doesn't vomit
before he goes on then he does because
he's not sure if he's in the zone well i
mean that is extreme but i totally can
identify with that and it's like um
like you're saying about kind of i'm not
nervous i'm excited like because the
what's happening in your body is like so
similar like they're actually
indistinguishable like excitement and
it's very much the story that you're
telling yourself that is determining
whether it is nerves or excitement yeah
exactly and i think for most people it's
a kind of combination like you're kind
of anxious but you're also excited
both you're feeling both of those things
because it's important to you and it's
almost just kind of recognizing that
fact that like you're doing this for a
purpose like most often people aren't
forcing you to do this you're doing it
because you're ambitious or because you
love to entertain or whatever and just
recognizing that fact that you're kind
of feeling these things for a reason
that can be really powerful
what was that study to do with people
pretending to be fighter pilots
ah yes this was to improve like vision
which is kind of crazy um
yeah
so they took like people with kind of
normal vision and some people who are a
bit kind of short-sighted um
and they just kind of told them to
pretend that you're a proper fighter
pilot so
they gave them a sight test first of all
and then put them in this you know hyper
realistic kind of flight simulation and
while they were doing that simulation
they had to kind of read off some codes
from the wings of the planes that they
were kind of flying around um and what
they found was that the people who
were doing that kind of hyper-realistic
simulation that they actually like that
eyesight physically improved so they
were able to see characters they were
much smaller than they had been able to
see on the kind of real sight test um
and then they repeated this experiment
in other settings that they
one of them was just like they took the
normal site test but you know it goes
from like big letters to small they just
reversed it um and the idea there was
that we have this kind of association
that the further down the test you go
the harder it is to see but at the top
you should be able to see and again they
were able to distinguish characters that
they hadn't been able to see before
you looked at willpower as well and i'd
heard this
i'd seen a story to do with was it roy
baumeister that did the original
willpower degradation studies yeah yeah
so i remember seeing uh
how would you say a prelude to the
expectation effect a few years ago when
i was reading about the fact that
um what's it it's not willpower
degradation what's it called um ego
depletion ego depletion that's it um ego
depletion
seems to be present only in the people
that know about ego depletion
yeah so tell what's the red pill that
people need to understand about
willpower yeah i mean it's totally
another expectation effect um so yeah
what's interesting is that in western
culture as a whole we've kind of had
this assumption that like um
when you practice kind of
mental focus or kind of um self-control
like when you're resisting temptation
that that is tiring and that it's gonna
the more you do it like the harder it's
gonna be essentially so
you know and that's exactly what people
like roy burnmeister heard
uh recorded you know like it's it is
like a muscle that you're kind of tiring
out and the longer you do it like the
more likely you are to kind of lose your
focus or um
uh give into temptation um but then they
did some studies in india where people
don't share that cultural belief so
actually in india it's much more common
for people to think that like willpower
is self uh perpetuating um it's almost
like they think like once you get into
the zone it's like easier to kind of
continue practicing your willpower it's
yeah it's like uh which is equally
plausible yeah totally yeah it's just
like anything like um once you get into
the kind of momentum going it kind of
can continue um
and so then they did the ego depletion
experiments with those people and they
found the total opposite actually
like um they didn't experience ego
depletion at all their willpower did
indeed crease increase the more they
practiced it so their focus was much
better on a second task compared to the
first task because i'd had this time to
kind of warm up um so that was really
strong evidence that like
yeah it's totally due to our underlying
beliefs about what's going to happen to
the brain it's purely an expectation
effect there's no kind of biological
cause for ego depletion does knowing
about the expectation effect or the
placebo effect change
the effect of it because i don't know if
we have created an information hazard
for everybody who's listening now that
could have blissfully
stumbled upon the expectation effect and
benefited from it but now they know the
fact that it's only a blah blah
no yeah i mean the great thing is it's
actually the opposite like um
knowing about the expectation effect can
actually make it more powerful in some
way and so we know this from
studies of placebos so like in a typical
placebo experiment you give someone a
painkiller uh you give someone a dummy
pill but you told them it's a painkiller
so it's like you have to be deceptive
um but then scientists started like
wondering well what happens if we
actually just give people a jar of
placebo pills
labelled as like placebo pills take two
a day can that actually improve their
pain just as well as the
uh kind of surreptitious placebos
um and they found that actually it can
so in this study from portugal they were
looking at people with chronic pain they
gave them um these pills and they also
gave them this kind of explanation of
the expectation effect so just a kind of
grounding in like what happens with the
mind-body connection how the brain can
produce its own painkillers you know all
of that information and then they just
gave people these pills and told them to
kind of take them twice a day and they
were really clear like you must take the
pills even though they're dummy pills
then five days later they had seen a
reduction in their symptoms already
there was about 30
um on the kind of standard score of pain
so that's the clinical threshold for any
new treatment like if a treatment's
effective you have to have a 30
reduction and these people were
experiencing that from
open label
placebos bottle it sell it yeah exactly
we need and actually you can buy like
placebo pills on amazon so
like it's already available if you want
it um
but actually like you know that's fine
like and if i had chronic pain i
probably would take like open label
placebos but actually there's just loads
of other ways you can like um
increase expectations without kind of
the sham treatments in medicine so
you know just like giving people
psychological therapy where you kind of
explain the importance of expectations
and then so if they've had heart surgery
you kind of just help them to kind of
set out a kind of framework for like how
they hope they will improve over the
next six months
that can also bring about this kind of
placebo-like response so you still see
kind of improvements in like biological
measures like the level of inflammation
that they're experiencing after the
operation how quickly they leave
hospital
you know how quickly they return to work
all of that just through honestly
helping people to change their
expectations
wasn't there something to do with
medicines where um people began to use
genuine medicines and then they were
either weaned off or the dose got
reduced or something because i imagine
that must be
let's say that you have a
drug that's got a
relatively toxic side effect perhaps or
there's a reason why you wouldn't want
to be on it longer term um you introduce
it you taper it down that would be
you get both sides right you've been
introduced to the experience you've got
that um
set the setting almost and then you you
dial it back and and people still get to
benefit
yeah i mean that's a really big hope for
like treating opioid addiction
essentially so there have been studies
looking at um
kind of people in rehab from like um
terrible injuries and like you do start
out by giving them an opioid drug but
very quickly you kind of you give them
the drug and then you give them
the placebo pill as well so they take
both together and you can strengthen it
even further by kind of associating both
with like a really strong smell so like
the smell of cardamom for example so so
you'd have like you'd sniff the cardamom
and you take the placebo and you take
the drug and then after a few days you
just stop or encourage them you don't
force them but you encourage them like
you don't need to take the drug anymore
just take the placebo pill and the
specific
yeah so this is like a pavlovian like uh
pavlovian weaning
yeah it's exactly that and then what
happens is the brain is already
responding it's being conditioned then
um to produce its own opioids and at a
much higher level than it would without
the conditioning response and so that
can really reduce like the amount of the
active drugs that people take and there
have been like case studies where people
have completely weaned themselves off
the opioids like quite quickly just by
using this technique
what was the thing to do with peanut
allergies
oh yeah yeah i mean that was that's one
of my favorite studies because i think
it again it shows just how we're like
we're talking about honestly reframing
stuff rather than like being delusional
um so like when kids have peanut
allergies you can actually train the
immune system to stop responding uh to
the peanut protein and it's just like
exposure therapy so you start off with
like a tiny dose of the protein and then
you build up over six months to hold
peanuts so by the end you know if a kid
is at a party they're accidentally like
a snickers bar or whatever they're not
going to be in danger having eaten that
because they've trained their body to
deal with it
but when when the kids do this therapy
it's like really uncomfortable you know
because the body is starting to have
like a mild allergic reaction as they
increase the doses so they get hives you
know uncomfortable feelings in their
mouth they might feel sick and all of
these things that are frightening and
kind of seem to be putting them in
danger and the researchers like just
tried to get them to reinterpret how
they saw those uh that discomfort so
they just said
this is rather than being dangerous this
is actually a sign that the treatment is
being effective it's like in the same
way when you're doing strength training
your muscles are gonna
start aching like you know you're this
is a sign that you're stimulating the
immune system and it's kind of learning
and responding um so
at the end of the trial those uh
patients had had that kind of training
and reframing they just reported fewer
side effects
um overall so it had reduced their
discomfort
but like even more impressively like it
had also changed the uh efficacy of the
treatment so those kids were actually
showing higher levels of this like
friendly antibody that can protect them
from the like overall like noxious um
allergic reaction it kind of just stops
the immune system from overreacting and
they had much higher levels than the
kids who who hadn't learned to reframe
these symptoms in that way
have you considered whether or not this
in part accounts for some of the side
effects we've seen with the recent
vaccine rollout
and the fact that people have
i mean has there ever been as widespread
of a medication with as many
uh disputed disputable side effects and
then people reporting them and all sorts
of stuff
yeah yeah yeah i mean totally it
definitely has had an effect like um and
you know like i think on social media
you could see everyone kind of sharing
their kind of war stories about having
the vaccine and then like being knocked
out for a couple of days or you know
having a bad headache or whatever so it
was very much like contagious these
expectations um
so the studies so far show that actually
you know these vaccines are quite
they definitely stimulate the immune
system so they do
cause like for some people about 25
percent of people they do lead to those
kinds of um
mild side effects so things like fatigue
maybe having a bit of a fever having a
headache you know that's all kind of to
be expected for like half of 25 of the
people having the vaccines but actually
in the um
in the trials you saw that the people
receiving the placebo injections were
also
um
quite likely to have those side effects
too so about half as many people had
those side effects in the placebo trials
so we know from that that yeah like
the vaccines themselves were causing
some of these like um slightly
uncomfortable side effects but the
expectations were causing it for a large
number of people too
and there was that thing at gatwick
airport which i remember from a few
years ago where it was all over the
press and the entire airport was shut
down and people were saying there was
drones absolutely everywhere but you
reckon that might be an expectation
effect as well
yeah i mean that was so yeah like in
2018 you know i think just one person
reported a drone and then like within a
couple of days like hundreds of people
said they've seen them um
but like the police and the army were
using like you know radar like they were
you know using all their technology to
kind of detect where these drones were
and like they couldn't find a single one
and no one took a photo of a drone that
could be verified that's it there was no
footage it didn't appear on any radar it
wasn't on any of the equipment and yet
you had this cascade of reports coming
in
yes so it just seems like it was yeah
like a contagious expectation effect and
so we know that the expectations can
shape perceptions and that it's like it
was priming people to see a drone when
like there was nothing in the sky
this would be interesting to look at if
there was a similar sort of event
happening again what you would
presumably expect
in terms of the number of reports would
be like a normal distribution curve
so you would have one a few a few more a
few more a few more a peak and then it
would begin to tail off i wonder if you
mapped those
onto a distribution
about whether or not it would come back
like that that would be interesting
yeah i mean i think anecdotally from
what the police had reported it did seem
like that with gatwick in that you did
start out with just one and then within
a couple of hours so maybe another
person had seen it but then as it kind
of got into the media you know and was
spread around the airport like yeah you
saw rapid increase and like there can't
have been that many drones around like
it would have just been impossible so i
mean
you can never rule out the possibility
that maybe the first report was genuine
but definitely like the airport didn't
need to be closed for like three days
and like disrupt all of those holidays
like yeah
one thing that you said earlier is
something i've been thinking about
recently which is this sort of culture
of generalized cynicism that we've got
at the moment and when you realize
you are right there's something
people think of it as
more rational
more cool almost to
be cynical
and and sort of blunt about most things
you see this
like in its extreme on the internet no
one is excitable on the internet
everyone's playing like a louis theroux
persona um and
yeah when you think about the fact that
that cynicism and the sort of public
messaging that we have and then the
social media like top-down public
messaging and then the bottom-up social
messaging that people see
literally could be
making people more sick more fat less
healthy stupider with side effects from
you know it's
everything cynicism cynicism genuinely
is kind of like a disease or a virus
yeah it totally is and like what really
annoys me is it's like um if you're
being like
like people think it's like super smart
to be skeptical but actually being
reflexively skeptical and just not
believing anything good
like to me that is like just as bad as
it's just as stupid yeah yeah exactly as
being totally gullible it's like you're
doing exactly the same thing it's just
you're taking the opposite viewpoint um
so yeah that drives me crazy and
especially like i see it a lot with like
um you know like as a science writer
like amongst my colleagues actually it's
kind of quite fashionable to always be
like super skeptical of any new and
exciting result but it's like that's not
that's not being like a better
journalist or like a more skeptical
thinker that's actually just like
kind of virtually signaling almost or
yeah like trying to prove your
intelligence without applying your
intelligence the programming is just as
simplistic it's just moving in the
opposite direction you haven't thought
about it either you haven't considered
it either you're just taking a heterodox
position in the hopes that this makes
you seem
cool and so what about the ethics then
do you think that there's an ethical
concern around deceiving somebody or
deceiving other people
even if it's in the service of making
their outcomes in life better
yeah and i do see it as like a big
ethical issue to like um deceive people
um and i think like in medicine you know
like um it's why these open label
placebos like the honest placebos are so
important because i think if you start
deceiving patients um
and then they find out they've been
deceived and then they're going to lose
like a lot of faith in the medical
profession and then that's going to
cause like problems further down the
line so i think we have to like you just
have to be honest for like the ethical
reasons but then i actually think like
when we know that you can
apply the expectation effect honestly
without any kind of problems anyway like
there's no need to be deceptive really
like you it is enough often just like in
so many of these studies it's enough
just to kind of
like tell people about the science that
you just give them like a kind of you
know popular science article that kind
of explains how like stress can be
beneficial to you or you know how you
can reframe the feelings of uh exercise
and that that can improve your
performance like you know very kind of
plain like not deceptive at all just
that information is enough like the
knowledge is power in these cases so
yeah i don't think we need to worry
about deception anymore
are there any
effects that
run counter to the expectation effect
are there any things that you found i
think you mentioned something to do with
uh constantly following happiness
as a
actually can make people less happy
which seems to kind of run in the
opposite direction were there any others
yeah i mean that so that's the main one
i think and yeah it's kind of like it
makes sense i mean so it's like
counter-intuitive but it's like if
you're
um
always trying to be happy like
the kind of converse of that is that
you're actually then like demonizing the
negative feelings you might be having
all the uncomfortable feelings you might
be having so it kind of is like um
an expectation effect and that is like
if you
want to be so happy that you think that
anytime you feel frustration or anxiety
it's a disaster you're kind of then
setting yourself up to like experience
those emotions um a lot more negatively
and to kind of for them to have a bigger
impact on your life um but yeah it is i
think like the simplistic view of the
expectation effect would just be it's
like tell yourself to be happy and you
will be happy but yeah that doesn't
happen um
so yeah i think we have to be careful to
kind of have the
to kind of outline the limits of the
expectation effect and the nuances it's
not always as simple as just kind of
hoping for the best you know um i also
just think we have to be honest about
the fact that like say in medicine like
say you've got like a terminal illness
or you know
like just improving your expectations
isn't going to help
you to get better like sometimes the
expectation effect just there's no
physiological mechanism by which it
could help you to
to kind of
benefit from the expectation effect
essentially so we we just have to be
careful to be honest about kind of when
it does work and when like you're not
going to expect to see like the full
benefit
is one of the most important things here
um
information or people's understanding on
knowledge around whatever the
experiences that they're going through
so for instance um talking about going
to the gym the understanding that one of
the byproducts of going to the gym is
going to be you sweating and you're
lifting you you feeling aches in your
muscles and stuff like that
that
knowledge enables the reframing right my
point is
is there a
it seems like one of the first steps to
becoming effective at the expectation
effect is
a degree of understanding or knowledge
around the specifics of whatever it is
that you're trying to get the effect to
work on is that right yeah it totally is
yeah exactly so it's like yeah we've
like exercise it helps for you to
understand like the exercise physiology
there and to understand why you're
feeling these things because otherwise
it's really easy for you to be like um
to catastrophize those feelings if you
don't understand the science of kind of
why they might be beneficial to you the
same with stress like you feel the
discomfort and if you don't understand
like some of the basics of the science
of like why we have the cortisol uh
spike at all um then yeah all you're
going to focus on is the negative
feelings and not necessarily on why it
might be useful so yeah i really do
think actually it's like just a bit of
scientific literacy and all of these
areas can go a long way to helping you
to reframe your expectations
that's one part of it right
what i want to try and get out of you is
what are the
common strategies if people want to
effectively apply the expectation effect
which aren't contingent on specific
knowledge about the thing that they're
trying to to use it on you know
reframing and all of that stuff what are
your
what's the the best framework that
you've come up with that people can take
away
um yeah i mean there's definitely some
things that i think you can do that like
whatever challenge you're facing it's
they're going to help you to form
better or more objective expectations um
and my favorite one is really this
process called like self-distancing and
so it was developed by ethan cross at
the university of michigan kind of
independently from the expectation
effect but
what he had noticed is that if you
the way you talk to yourself is often
really different from the way you would
talk to a friend so you're much more
self-critical and much more negative
when you talk to yourself
compared to if you're advising someone
who's in exactly the same position
um and so his solution to that is just
to imagine that you're advising your
friend like when you're talking to
yourself
and you can even use like the third
person kind of language so you can be
like i could be like uh
you know it sounds stupid it sounds like
elmo from sesame street or whatever but
it could be like um
you know
like david's worried about i don't know
like um getting older david feels but
he's gonna be like vulnerable and you
know suffer from decline you know all of
that um but the fact is like if you were
talking to yourself you might be like
look in the mirror see some wrinkles and
be like oh god i look hideous this is
awful like it's only going to get worse
if you were talking to your friend like
you would be like no you're still fine
like um there's still lots to look
forward to like you know don't be so
defeated like you can still grow you can
still like there's still stuff that you
can do and achieve like as you're
getting older um and so yeah i think
that's just something that i found super
helpful like whenever i am kind of
wrestling with like needlessly negative
expectations it's just to kind of shift
perspective and think like would i
actually talk to other people
and and like tell them the things that
i'm telling myself
and that's
use the third person with an in a
monologue and also imagine that you were
saying it to somebody else
yeah exactly and treat yourself with the
kind of compassion that you would treat
someone else basically so
david this is great now this is a really
really cool effect i'm very very glad
that you've written the book if people
want to see what you do why should they
go online
so my website is davidrobson.me
i'm d underscore a underscore robson on
twitter
i'm on linkedin yeah but i mean
basically twitter or my website is the
best place dude i really appreciate you
coming on today thank you cool yeah it's
been my pleasure thanks what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace